how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some really big guardians of the
galaxy volume 3 news to talk about today
in a recent interview James Gunn the
director of guardians of the galaxy
volume 1 volume 2 and the upcoming
volume 3 opened up about the script of
guardians volume 3 including one big
detail in one character story arc that
is going to be coming to an end with
guardians 3 so I'll break down what he
said in this video but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe to my channel
at the 400,000 subscriber mark I'll be
choosing three winners and each will get
to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection so as I
mentioned in a recent interview with
deadline James Gunn opened up about
being fired and rehired from Disney to
direct the guardians franchise and in
the interview he revealed a major plot
point for guardians three he told
deadlines when you asked me what was
saddest for me when I thought it was
gone and anybody at Marvel can tell you
it's this very strange in a tax
relationship to rocket rocket is me he
really is even if that sounds
narcissistic Groot is like my dog
I love Groot in a completely different
way I relate to rocket and I feel
compassion for rocket but I also feel
like his story has not been completed he
has an arc that started in the first
movie continued into the second and goes
through infinity war and endgame and
then I was set to really finish that arc
in guardians 3 that was a big loss to me
not being able to finish that story
though I was comforted by the fact that
they were still planning to use my
script so according to what James Gunn
said in that interview Rocket Raccoon
story arc is going to be coming to an
end in guardians of the galaxy vol 3
there have been some recent leaks
stating that rocket racoons creator is
actually the High Evolutionary and that
we're going to see all of this play out
in Guardians 3 and that leak seems to
line up with what James Gunn is saying
about finishing rocket story arc
we've only briefly heard about Rocket
being created but we know nothing about
where he came from or who created him
so if guardians 3 is going to wrap up
his story arc will most likely find out
who created him and according to this
leak it is the High Evolutionary which
means we'll be seeing the High
Evolutionary in Guardians 3 the same
person leaked that we would actually see
lady lila in guardians 3 who is Rocket
Raccoon soulmate in the comics after a
huge war lady lila in rock
leave together to start a new life and
if this is really the end of rocket
story arc in the MCU we could see this
happen at the end of guardians 3 so
according to what James Gunn said in the
recent interview with deadline Rocket
Raccoon story arc will be coming to an
end with guardians of the galaxy vol 3
and we will be seeing who made rocket
who is supposedly the High Evolutionary
according to some leaks and Rocket will
get a love interest so let me know what
you think about this news in the
comments down below and again don't
forget about my giveaway at the 400,000
subscriber mark I'll be picking three
winners and each will get to choose one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection you must be subscribed to my
channel to enter for a chance to win be
sure to let me know your thoughts and be
sure to drop a like if you enjoyed the
video and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]